nous avons le plaisir ce matin
d'accueillir pour la première fois de la
dictature le président de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique la hatv Monsieur Didier afin
qu'il nous présente le dernier rapport
d'activité de cette autorité essentielle
au bon fonctionnement de notre
démocratie il s'agit vous le savez du
rapport de l'année 2022 qui vient d'être
publié que chacun d'entre nous a eu le
plaisir de consulter puisqu'il était mis
à votre disposition je rappelle que la
htvp a été créée par la loi du 11
octobre 2013 relative à la transparence
de la vie publique qu'elle comprend 13
membres nommé pour Amanda 6 ans non
renouvelable et soumis au secret
professionnel et la 3 mission principale
garantir la déontologie des responsables
publics encadré les activités de
reprendre en intérêt et diffuser une
culture de l'intégrité monsieur le
Président 2022 ayant été une année
électorale l'activité de la hatvp a
logiquement été marquée par le contrôle
d'un très grand nombre de déclarations
d'intérêts et de patrimoine selon votre
apport plus de 10000 mais le champ de
beaux travaux est plus large et votre
apport comprend 8 principales recomm que
vous souhaiterez certainement nous
présenter et avant de vous donner la
parole et de laisser à nos collègues le
loisir de vous interroger pour une durée
limitée de deux minutes j'ai souhaité
dans déjà vous dresser quelques
questions d'abord sur cette année 2022
que j'ai dit que marqué par les
échéances électorales pour que vous
disiez si selon vous les élus et
principalement les parlementaires se
sont conformés au mieux ou en tout cas
s'ils se seront davantage conformés aux
obligations qu'il leur racontent que ces
dernières années la deuxième question à
très registre des représentants
d'intérêt qui étaient étendu aux actions
de lobbying menées en direction des
collectivités territoriales et
j'aimerais connaître le bilan que vous
en tirez compte tenu des nouvelles
obligations qui leur incomment quant à
ce registre de reprendre en intérêt il
permet d'identifier aussi les gens de
savoir s'il permet d'identifier les
ingérences étrangères vous savez que il
y a une législation américaine le Farah
qui permet de d'enregistrer les
influences et les ingérences étrangères
je sais aussi que le Parlement
britannique étudie la nationale security
Bill qui à instaurer un fichier dit de
fears et qui recoure aussi la DPR rendre
un rapport sur les ingérences étrangères
très bientôt et sans déplorer des
conclusions je crois qu'elle préconisera
son président d'avoir ce type d'action à
l'égard des des influences et ingérence
étrangères et je voulais savoir quel
était l'avis de la télé à cet égard et
enfin la chattevp a vu s'étendre sa
compétence considérablement en matière
de contrôle je l'ai dit notamment pour
les collectivités diriez-vous que elles
accusent un retard en matière de
transparence et de culture de la
transparence des livres qu'elles sont
particulièrement exposées conflit
d'intérêt et pour finir c'est peut-être
le dernier élément je sais que la liste
des représentants intérêts et désormais
en tout cas tenu façon assez stricte
assez détaillée par l'htv est-ce que
vous rencontrez des difficultés avec un
certain catégorie de personnes je pense
notamment à des personnes morales
associatives qui s'estimeraient ne pas
devoir remplir leurs obligations
déclaratives notamment parce que leurs
causes quel juge légitime les en
exonérer voilà les cinq questions que
j'ai à vous poser qui sont à mon avis
importantes et qui justifient ce matin
votre audition je vous donne la parole
et ensuite je prendrai les droits
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés merci pour votre
invitation à vous présenter le rapport
d'activité de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
2022 vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président a été une année exceptionnelle
pour les responsables publics et la
Haute Autorité vous le savez le socle de
la Haute Autorité c'est l'accompagnement
le contrôle
de 18000 responsables publics élus comme
non élus afin de s'assurer de l'absence
de conflit d'intérêt d'enrichissement
personnel de contribuer à garantir aux
yeux des citoyens la probité des
responsables publics c'est aussi le
contrôle des mobilités professionnelles
entre les secteurs publics et privés de
15000 agents publics exerçant les
fonctions les plus stratégiques alors
l'enjeu est important il était d'autant
plus en 2022 que c'était une année
chargée sur le plan politique et
électoral
2022 ainsi donné lieu à une intense
activité d'accompagnement et de conseils
de la Haute Autorité nous avons renforcé
nos activités d'accompagnement de nos
publics dès la fin de l'année 2021
accompagnement individuel par téléphone
ou par écrit
session d'information webinaire à
l'intention justement de celles et ceux
qui doivent remplir des déclarations et
pour chacune des échéances électorales
nous avons procédé à de très nombreuses
relances lors des campagnes de dépôt
pour que les déclarants respectent les
délais que prévoit la loi
il y a eu une intense activité
déclarative de la part des responsables
publics 5245 responsables et agents
publics ont déposé plus de
10659 déclarations de patrimoine ou
d'intérêt auprès de la Haute Autorité
41 dossiers concernant principalement
des des élus locaux ont été transmis au
procure de la République pour non dépôt
de déclaration alors nous observons des
des taux de dépôt dans les délais avant
relance qui sont inégaux
selon les catégories de responsables
publics ils sont en amélioration depuis
un certain nombre d'années en témoignent
d'ailleurs celui des députés élus en
2022 nettement meilleur quand 2017
des divergences sont néanmoins observés
entre le dépôt des déclarations
initiales celle que vous déposez au
début de vos fonctions et celle de fin
de mandat pour l'ensemble des déclarants
le taux de dépôt dans les délais des
déclarations de situations patrimoniale
de fin de mandat et de 49% seulement
contre 74% pour les déclarations
initiales il y a donc quelques marges de
progrès
d'où un travail important de relance
545 relances pour non dépôt dans le
délai ont été adressés
193 injonctions après relance et je le
disais 41 dossiers transmis au procureur
de la République pour défaut de
déclaration
donc
cette intense activité déclarative
implique une intense activité de
contrôle de la situation des
responsables publics
4170 déclarations étaient contrôlées
notamment des responsables publics parmi
les plus les plus importants
déposés en début et en fin de mandat
alors la part des déclarations initiales
entièrement conforme aux exigences
d'exhaustivité d'exactitude et de
sincérité que nous impose la loi au
niveau du contrôle demeure stable c'est
de l'ordre d'un tiers
plus de 60% des déclarations contrôlées
font l'objet de demande de modification
dans l'objectif de rendre ces
déclarations plus claires et plus exact
pour le citoyen 10 dossiers ont été
transmis à la justice pour des
manquements déclaratifs ou des
manquements à la probité j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir 10 dossiers 41
dossiers c'est peu de dossiers
par rapport à la totalité des personnes
concernées pour répondre à votre
question j'y reviendrai dans dans
l'ensemble l'immense majorité des
responsables publics remplissent
correctement leurs obligations
déclaratives alors l'activité de
contrôle des déclarations et
d'accompagnement des députés des membres
du gouvernement a été particulièrement
soutenue les contrôles approfondis de la
Haute Autorité ont contribué à améliorer
significativement la qualité des éclairs
des déclarations mise à la disposition
des citoyens la prévention des conflits
d'intérêts est un objectif majeur et un
sujet qui retient
vous le savez tout particulièrement
l'attention de la société civile s'il
n'est pas interdit heureusement
d'ailleurs d'avoir des intérêts même des
conflits entre ces différents intérêts
la neutralité de la décision publique
doit toujours être protégée car elle
vise l'intérêt général ainsi plusieurs
membres du gouvernement se sont vus
imposer un décret de déport destinés à
prévenir les risques de conflit
d'intérêt ou de prise illégale d'intérêt
alors plus largement
notamment au niveau des élus locaux 7
contrôles de déclaration sur 10
conduisent la Haute Autorité à demander
des mesures de prévention d'une
situation de conflit
d'intérêt je réponds là à une de vos
questions
ça n'est pas anormal qu'il y ait plus de
déclarations d'intérêt au niveau des
élus locaux qui nécessitent de notre
part un certain nombre de mesures de
prévention à partir du moment où quand
on est élu local très souvent on
continue d'avoir des activités
professionnelles d'où un risque là de
conflit d'intérêt nous avons publié
récemment notre doctrine en matière de
conflit d'intérêt public pour les élus
locaux à la suite de l'adoption de la
loi 3 3DS qui
pour partie pour partie seulement à plus
clarifier les sujets de conflits
d'intérêts publics puisque nous savons
vous avez que que la la France est le
seul pays d'ailleurs à connaître un
conflit d'intérêt public public
lors de la publication des déclarations
d'intérêts d'activités des députés la
Haute Autorité également diffusée une
analyse des données qu'elle contiennent
elles portaient sur les activités
professionnelles des députés de la 16e
législature mais aussi sur leurs
fonctions et mandats électriques et
comprenez les comparaisons avec les
résultats de l'étude portant sur la
législature précédente cette analyse a
montré notamment que
l'Assemblée nationale renouvelé pour
moitié suite aux dernières élections
législatives étaient composées dans sa
grande majorité de députés qui avaient
exercé une activité professionnelle au
cours des cinq années précédent leur
mandat
70%, les deux tiers d'entre elles étant
exercé dans le secteur privé un député
sur 6 entendait conservé au moins une
activité professionnelle au cours de son
mandat
et un député sur deux détiens un autre
mandat électif dans près de 40% desquels
il s'agit d'un mandat de conseiller
municipal
une dernière
statistique qui peut vous intéresser les
déclarations publiques sur
le site ont été consultés plus d'un
million de fois
enfin qui dit année politique électorale
exceptionnelle dit aussi année
exceptionnelle en matière de contrôle
des mobilités publiques privées alors la
Haute Autorité joue ici un rôle de
régulation elle est systématiquement à
la recherche d'un équilibre entre
différents intérêts à concilier
permettre des passages entre les
secteurs publics et privés contrairement
parfois ce que j'entends ça n'est pas
interdit tout en veillant à défendre
l'impartialité de l'action publique et
protéger les responsables et agents
publics contre les risques de nature
pénale et déontologique pouvant résulter
de leur projet
et là peut-être que j'aurai l'occasion
de répondre à des questions mais nous
appelons strictement la loi votée par le
législateur 2022 a été marquée par un
nombre de saisines records
639 en augmentation de 93% par rapport à
l'année dernière
nous nous sommes organisés pour traiter
l'ensemble dans des délais raisonnables
souvent bien dans de ça des délais
légaux en particulier des avis
préalables à la nomination des
collaborateurs du Président de la
République ou des membres de cabinets
ministériels ayant exercé dans le
secteur privé
ils sont d'ailleurs à peu près de
l'ordre de 30% dans les cabinets
ministériels
issus du privé donc à chaque fois la
Haute Autorité doit
exprimer un avis de prédomination et dès
que les personnes repartent dans le
privé ils doivent y avoir également un
avis de la Haute Autorité alors
s'agissant plus précisément des
mobilités vers le secteur privé qui
mettent davantage en jeu la nécessité de
protéger
l'intérêt public près de 80% des avis
sont des avis de compatibilité avec
réserve
réserve qui sont destinées à prévenir
les risques d'ordre pénal ou déontologie
les avis d'incompatibilité
adopter lorsque aucune mesure de
précaution ne permet de prévenir les
risques
identifiés concernent principalement
ces projets de reconversion
professionnelle qui présentent plus de
risques de nature à compromettre
l'indépendance et l'impartialité de
l'administration ou de prise illégale
d'intérêt ces avis d'incompatibilité
stricts sont de l'ordre de
6,3%. ça relativise aussi quelques
commentaires que l'on peut entendre ici
ou là les avis de 10 recevabilité et
d'incompétence sont désormais en nombre
très limité moins de 4% à comparer avec
les 30% constatés en 2020 ça ça traduit
je crois une meilleure appropriation de
des autorités hiérarchiques dans dans
l'administration de ces nouvelles
dispositions législatives votées en 2019
quatre dossiers ont été transmis à la
justice dans le cadre du contrôle des
mobilités entre les secteurs publics et
privés
en 2022 a été aussi une année charnière
pour la régulation de la représentation
d'intérêt s'agissant de l'activité de
contrôle de la Haute Autorité l'année
2022 a été marquée par une très forte
augmentation du nombre de mises en
demeure de représentants d'intérêts
inscrits au registre pour défaut de
déclaration 76 mise en demeure contre
une en 2021 19 d'entre elles ont été
rendues publiques sur le site de la
Haute autorité qui pour la première fois
transmis 8 dossiers au parc
lorsqu'elle dépose les entités inscrites
doivent bien sûr convenablement déclarer
leurs actions de représentation
d'intérêts 55 contrôles au conduit à des
modifications sur ce point il s'agissant
des non inscrits les contrôles de la
Haute Autorité ont conduit à
l'inscription de 38 organismes
l'inscription est évidemment essentielle
car c'est bien elle qui permet aux
citoyens de s'informer sur l'affluence
de la société civile sur la décision
publique en 2022 était également l'année
de l'extension du dispositif
d'encadrement de la représentation
d'intérêts collectivités territoriales
et à certains agents publics entrés en
vigueur le 1er juillet nous avons
produit plusieurs ressources
documentaires destinées à faciliter son
appropriation par les représentants
d'intérêt dont un vademecom consacré à
l'identification des nouveaux
responsables publics auprès desquels une
entrée en communication pouvait être
qualifiée d'action de représentation
d'intérêts nous avons eu aussi des
échanges avec
les associations d'élus et les
associations de représentants d'intérêts
cette intégration du lobbying à
l'échelon locale à entraîner plus de 300
nouvelles inscriptions représentant près
du quart de l'ensemble des activités
déclarées pour l'année 2022
sur pour répondre à votre question
oui il y a des réticences parfois à
vouloir s'inscrire sur le registre des
représentants d'intérêts certains
estimant que
leurs travaux
étant d'intérêt général ils n'ont pas à
s'inscrire sur le répertoire des
représentants de l'intérêt on a eu
quelques échanges parfois difficiles
avec notamment un certain nombre de
signes tank bon nous leur avons expliqué
que le législateur n'avait pas fait
d'ailleurs de distinction entre
l'intérêt général et les intérêts
particuliers et que à partir du moment
où on intervenait pour
influencer une décision publique ça
pouvait être considéré comme une action
de représentation d'intérêts au terme de
la loi et que le législateur a prévu
d'exclure un certain nombre de
catégories de du périmètre de la loi
mais n'a pas écarté les Sims tanks voilà
donc nous verrons puisque nous avons
l'Institut Montaigne qui qui a engagé
une action devant le
à la fois en référé et sur le fond
remettant en cause une demande de
renseignement exprimée de de notre part
l'action référée a été jugé était
repoussé donc nous attendons maintenant
la décision de fond du Conseil d'État je
m'étonne parfois des arguments avancés
pour remettre en cause l'inscription au
répertoire des représentants d'intérêt
en disant que ça pouvait remettre en
cause l'indépendance
ou bien
la liberté des symptômes je ne pense pas
que le législateur en mettant en place
le registre de représentants d'intérêt a
voulu remettre en cause l'indépendance
ni la liberté des personnes susceptibles
d'être inscrite on entend parfois des
arguments curieux en défense pour
essayer de se soustraire un certain
nombre d'obligations imposées par la loi
alors la question de la régulation du
lobbying à l'échange locale va
constituer sûrement un enjeu majeur des
années à venir il est important que ces
acteurs s'approprient de dispositif en
vigueur nous allons publier
prochainement de nouvelles lignes
directrices
autre enjeu en matière d'influence et la
question de l'âge étrangère qui retient
beaucoup l'attention c'est ces derniers
mois étant précisé que ce sujet porte
autant
sur porte sur plusieurs missions
d'ailleurs que peut avoir la Haute
Autorité
notamment la régulation du lobbying les
mobilités publiques privées avec la
possibilité de rejoindre tel ou tel
entreprise sous influence
étrangère et le contenu des déclarations
d'intérêts de patrimoine qui doivent
aussi faire Ethan un certain nombre
d'informations alors ces enjeux alors
nous nous sommes convenus d'ailleurs
nous avons lancé un travail en relation
avec l'OCDE sur ce sur ce sujet et
dès que ce travail sera réalisé je serai
votre disposition bien sûr pour vous le
présenter et étant entendu que que c'est
un sujet majeur aujourd'hui on le voit
bien
par rapport à aux activités d'un certain
nombre de pays alors tous ces enjeux
montrent aussi je sais que vous y êtes
sensible qu'une révision du dispositif
d'encadrement du lobbying et de plus en
plus souhaitable
j'ai eu au cours l'occasion au cours de
ces derniers mois de m'exprimer à de
nombreuses reprises sur le sujet
d'ailleurs été auditionné par par vous
ou par d'autres commissions au Sénat 8
reprises
sur une période de 2 à 3 ans sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets ou à chaque
fois nous nous sommes efforcés de
faire le bilan de
la mise en place de ce répertoire qui
est selon nous un bilan de mitainte à la
fois un bilan extrêmement positif à
partir du moment où la loi Sapin 2 à
reconnu d'une certaine façon la
représentation d'intérêt c'est une
activité qui existe qui est qui est
légitime le problème c'est que elle doit
pouvoir se faire en toute transparence
et respecter un certain nombre de règles
déclaratives et déontologiques alors là
la difficulté c'est que
il y a un certain nombre de possibilités
de contourner la loi
que
le dispositif en vigueur ne permet pas
toujours de d'avoir les informations
nécessaires pour assurer justement la
transparence qui avait voulu le
législateur à l'époque sur la
traçabilité et l'influence sur la
décision publique d'où un certain nombre
de propositions que l'on peut faire pour
conforter ce ce dispositif
et je suis prêt bien sûr à répondre à
vos questions la dessus il y a un
certain nombre d'aberrations qui ont été
bien bien identifiés je crois par un
certain nombre de missions d'information
mise en place par votre commission des
Lois par la Mission flash qui
a eu l'occasion de formuler un certain
nombre de propositions tout ou récemment
bon il y a cette curiosité que que les
actions de représentation d'intérêt
s'apprécient au niveau des personnes
physiques et non pas de la personne
morale
alors même que on voit bien que c'est au
niveau de l'entité de la personne morale
que il peut être intéressant
d'identifier les influences sur la
décision publique le critère de
l'initiative a pour conséquence que les
grosses entités
non pratiquement rien à déclarer à
partir du moment où
elles sont systématiquement invitées par
les pouvoirs publics systématiquement
consultés et le paradoxe c'est donc que
je sais pas la fédération de boucherie
de tel département
a plus d'obligations déclaratives que
tel ou telle grosse entreprise française
telle ou telle grande entreprise
française vous constaterez en regardant
notre répertoire que des entreprises
comme Dassault ou Vinci déclare en fait
assez peu d'action
je crois qu'il serait naïve de penser
que ces entreprises n'interviennent
jamais pour essayer d'influencer la
législation où là réglementation
alors nous sommes dix ans après les lois
de 2013 et il y a un certain nombre
de choses qui sont effectivement
extrêmement positives
mais des évolutions
restent selon nous possible et
nécessaire pour aller plus loin
je crois que le bilan de la Haute
Autorité est aujourd'hui reconnu que la
Haute Autorité est ancrée dans le
paysage institutionnel français son
champ d'intervention s'est accrue au fil
des ans
par des missions nouvelles que lui a
confié le législateur preuve de la
confiance je crois que lui accorde le
législateur les nous aurons d'ailleurs
l'occasion d'organiser la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale la accepté un
colloque en octobre je vous en ai dit un
mot aussi monsieur le Président sur les
10 ans justement de la Haute Autorité
les principaux responsables de agents
publics sont désormais accompagnés
contrôlés tout au long de leur fonction
que ce soit lors de leur entrée dans la
vie publique pendant ou lorsqu'ils en
sortent dix ans après c'est
un recul intéressant pour savoir comment
pourrait être évoluer encore le
dispositif français de l'intégrité il
doit pouvoir évoluer en référence à ce
qui se fait dans dans d'autres pays où à
l'initiative d'institutions comme le CDE
le Greco qui travaille beaucoup sur ces
sujets là cette dimension internationale
est importante c'est la raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle nous avons
souhaité créer avec 11 autres pays de de
l'Union européenne un réseau européen
d'éthique public chargé de porter des
propositions auprès des institutions de
l'Union européenne et autour de la Haute
Autorité la dynamique doit être globale
se faire bien sûr en coordination avec
les différents acteurs de la probité les
référents déontologues que vous avez
institué
en font partie et c'est pourquoi nous y
portons une attention toute particulière
en échangeant régulièrement en étant à
la disposition d'ailleurs de ces
référents des écolos déontologues pour
leur faire connaître la doctrine de la
Haute autorité pour organiser des
rencontres annuelles nous les avons
d'ailleurs réunis la semaine dernière au
Sénat il y avait à peu près 150
référents déontologues qui étaient
présents en nous formulons vous l'avez
dit un certain nombre de
propositions de depuis un certain nombre
d'années
nous souhaiterions que que la Haute
Autorité puisse être dotée d'un d'un
pouvoir de sanctions propres alors
l'idée n'est surtout pas de se
substituer au juge pénal mais en
certaines circonstances une amende
administrative nous paraît plus
appropriée
qu'une poursuite
euh au niveau pénal je pense notamment
lorsque
un déclarant justement ne remplit pas
ses obligations déclaratives à la fois
de déclaration d'intérêt comme le
déclaration de de patrimoine nous
pensons qu'une sanction administrative
serait beaucoup plus rapide beaucoup
plus incitative là aujourd'hui que
faisons-nous dans ce type de situation
qui une fois de plus sont extrêmement
peu nombreuses nous avons transmis une
quarantaine de dossiers sur l'année 2022
bon mais ce sont des situations qui qui
marquent parce que le citoyen s'en rend
compte et qui du coup rejaillissent sur
l'ensemble et le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que
ceux qui ne déposent pas
sont
extrêmement rarement sanctionné
puisque nous leur adressons des relances
une injonction et une fois les relances
passées une fois les injonctions passées
nous transmettons parquet mais nous
avons des parquets qui sont assez
débordés bon et qui peuvent ne pas
toujours considérer ces sujets comme
étant prioritaires ce qui fait que on
peut avoir
deux ans ou trois ans après des
personnes non sanctionnées avec des
citoyens qui nous interpellent en disant
mais on comprend pas sur votre site tel
élu qui vous devez des déclarations
d'intérêt des déclarations de patrimoine
ne les a pas remplies et qu'en est-il
bah voilà on ne peut que répondre que
pour le moment aucune sanction n'a est
très prise donc c'est pour cela que que
nous souhaiterions que dans ce type de
situation on puisse effectivement avant
de transmettre au juge pénal s'il y a
récidive
pouvoir
à travers une commission des sanctions
qui seraient indépendante bien sûr du
collège de la Haute Autorité pouvoir
décider d'une amende d'une amende
administrative dans cette situation
parce que non seulement il y a non
respect de la loi avec le nom des pots
mais pendant tout ce temps là il n'y a
pas de contrôle bon ni de mesure de
prévention d'ailleurs de conflits
d'intérêts donc c'est une situation qui
est doublement gênante
nous formulons aussi une proposition
s'agissant des ministres
nous constatons que que le délai de
dépôt des déclarations d'intérêt pour
les ministres peut peut
se serviront puisqu'ils ont deux mois
pour déposer une déclaration d'intérêt
comme leur déclarations de patrimoine
pour déclaration de patrimoine ça ne
pose pas de difficultés deux mois pour
une déclaration d'intérêts avec en plus
le mois ou les deux mois de contrôle
nécessaire pour la Haute Autorité ça
peut faire trois quatre mois pendant ce
temps là des ministres peuvent
parfaitement se trouver en situation de
conflits d'intérêt voire même de prise
illégale d'intérêt donc
nous avons attiré l'attention du du
président de la République et de la
première ministre ce point et et
nous leur avons proposé que dès la
première semaine
de nomination le ministre puisse
s'interroger sur
en liaison avec le secrétariat général
du gouvernement avec nous-mêmes
d'ailleurs nous sommes tout à fait
disponibles bien sûr pour les ministres
pour analyser leur situation pour qu'ils
puissent
prévenir toute situation de conflit
d'intérêt que des des
arrêtés de déport des décrets de déport
puissent être pris le plus rapidement
possible nous proposons aussi
qu'un certain nombre de responsables qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dans le champ de
contrôle des mobilités puissent le
devenir je pense par exemple au
président de l'UGAP au responsable de
l'UGAP
aux responsables de solideo qui vous le
savez et la société qui justement a
beaucoup de contacts dans le cadre de
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
toutes les entreprises ces personnes là
lorsqu'elles
souhaitent aller dans le privé ne sont
pas contrôlés comme d'autres leçons et
les risques sont d'autant plus forts
lorsque vous êtes à la tête
d'établissement public comme Lugia pour
ou comme solideo
enfin je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
nous proposons que le dispositif
d'encadrement du lobbying puisse être
simplifié
à la fois avec un certain nombre de
précisions qui pourraient être apportées
par le législateur avec la question du
critère d'initiative mais aussi avec la
nécessité selon nous de mieux définir le
champ de la décision publique concernée
bon nous avons un décret qui
dans son envolée bon à considérer que
toute décision publique pouvait être
concernée par le dispositif ce qui
pose un vrai sujet de définition du
chant de la décision publique concernée
surtout lorsque vous étendez le
dispositif aux collectivités
territoriales donc il serait nous
serions tout à fait preneur que le
législateur puisse cerner
les la décision publique qui doit être
concernée par le dispositif alors
l'ensemble de ces évolutions pourrait
contribuer à renforcer la confiance des
citoyens dans leur représentants nous
sommes parfois accusés d'accentuer une
forme de suspicion à l'égard des
responsables publics lorsque nous
opposons à une mobilité vers le privé ou
lorsque nous transmettons un dossier au
Parquet
je considère que ce n'est pas en cassant
le thermomètre que l'on fait baisser la
fièvre et je pense que
toutes ces évolutions ont été
extrêmement utiles l'ensemble de nos
contrôles je n'hésite pas à le à le
répéter à le dire démontre que l'immense
majorité des responsables publics
exercent leur mission avec profiter avec
honnêteté alors il y a des manquements
qui existent ils sont regrettables
heureusement marginaux et en toute
petite quantité alors malgré cela il y a
un fort sentiment de défiance et nous
constatons nous un décalage entre ce
sentiment de défiance qui existe dans
l'opinion publique les dernières
enquêtes ces vipof montrent que deux
tiers des Français estiment que leur
responsable public leurs élus ne sont
pas honnêtes bon ce qui ce qui est grave
dans une démocratie ce qui est
préoccupant et cela ne correspond pas du
tout
résultat des contrôles que nous faisons
bon puisque nous pouvons constater
qu'une immense majorité des responsables
publics exercent leur fonction de façon
très très honnête alors je crois qu'il
faut je crois que les citoyens
ignorent en grande partie
tout ce qui a été mis en place depuis un
certain nombre d'années sur le contrôle
des responsables publics moi il m'arrive
de faire des conférences à l'intention
des citoyens je constate qu'à la fin il
pose énormément de questions
à la fin d'ailleurs ils disent nous ne
savions pas tout ça bon mais aussi bien
sur les ministres que sur les
parlementaires que sur les responsables
publics il y a aujourd'hui des contrôles
on identifie mieux ceux qui manquent à
leurs obligations et aujourd'hui la
justice sanctionne beaucoup plus qui
hier ce type de comportement donc ces
contrôles ne doivent pas être vu je
pense par les responsables publics comme
une contrainte mais au contraire comme
un moyen de de garantir aux citoyens que
que l'exercice des fonctions se fait
tout à fait honnêtement
je plaide pour ma part pour que vous
puissiez en parler plus souvent
que une politique publique de lutte
contre les atteintes à la probité soit
mieux identifiée qu'elle ne peut l'être
aujourd'hui dans notre pays elle est
très dispersée vous n'en parlez jamais
le Parlement dans des bas jamais sauf
quand il s'agit de mettre en place des
dispositifs après des scandales et je
trouve que plus on parle des choses plus
ça peut
faire comprendre aux citoyens qu'il y a
un certain nombre de dispositifs qui
existent et qui sont là pour leur
garantir justement cette probité il
serait logique se trouve que le
Parlement puisse s'en débattre chaque
année au niveau d'une mission qui leur
serait présentée chaque année également
au niveau aussi de l'appréciation des
résultats de cette politique publique
qui peut-être mis en place je pense que
ça pourrait ça pourrait même si je suis
bien conscient que que on n'est pas
obligatoirement la seule raison de la
défiance des citoyens vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des responsables publics élus
mais pas seulement y compris vis-à-vis
des autorités administratives
indépendantes mais que ça pourrait quand
même contribuer à conforter la confiance
ou à faire diminuer cette défiance voilà
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés j'ai peut-être été
un peu trop long mais voilà le rapport
d'activité que je voulais vous présenter
je vous remercie abandonné la parole de
nos collègues peut-être j'ai évidemment
je vous remercie d'avoir pour les
réponses que vous avez apportées aux
questions que j'ai posées à toutes ce
qui était rare de répondre à toutes les
questions puisque c'est souvent envie de
les reposer vous dire simplement que
avec malgré tous les accords que j'ai
avec vous ce que vous avez dit c'est une
réserve puisque l'une des premières lois
de 2017 concernait justement la
transparence dans la dans la vie
politique avec des évolutions ensuite
qui ont concerné le bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale des évolutions
extrêmement importantes qui ignorent nos
concitoyens sur les la suppression des
régimes spéciaux de retraite la
suppression des régimes spéciaux de
retour à l'emploi l'alignement pour les
questions de contrôle des frais de
mandat l'interdiction de l'emploi pour
les parlementaires la suppression de
certaines mesures qui font aujourd'hui
débat mais de mon point de vue sur tout
à fait justifiés de la réserve
parlementaire avec cette allocation
discrétionnaire pour le parlementaire
d'une partie de subvention et puis la
mission d'un flash qui était confié à
nos collègues d'une
a priori de créer qui relevait donc de
la compétence du gouvernement pour la
question de l'encadrement du registre
des représentants d'intérêt et qui
donnera certainement lieu à une
proposition loi transpartienne c'est mon
souhait donc un débat un débat au
Parlement ce qui veut dire aussi que à
la commission des lois nous nous
saisissons de ces objets et votre et
votre audition ici en est un témoignage
assez certain avec les évolutions
législatives que
la Commission
c'est une façon d'appréciation
d'ensemble c'est une façon de mettre en
perspective et en lumière le travail que
de conduisant en tout cas nous sommes
ravis de vous recevoir aujourd'hui et en
témoigne la liste des inscrits que je
vais énumérer désormais Monsieur
Jean-Pierre con
oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président merci de votre présence
monsieur le Président et d'une certaine
façon à votre tour de votre déclaration
devant la commission des lois
l'obligation de déclaration de situation
matrimoniale et déclaration d'intérêts
permettent une transparence
indispensable à la vie politique cette
transparence ne se limite pas en début
et en fin de mandat puisque toutes
modification doit être rapidement
notifiée à la hatpv notamment les
modifications personnelles familiales
actuellement il faut aussi détailler
ligne par ligne par exemple un plan
d'épargne action mais vos services par
leurs compétences et leur efficacité
nous apportent une aide précieuse
permettez-moi maintenant de revenir sur
un autre aspect ces déclarations à votre
organisme son public
loin de moi l'idée de contester ce point
mais leur confidentialité me semble
anormalement et fréquemment remise en
cause
comme vous ne l'ignorez pas à
contribuable s'il résiste dans le même
département est en droit de consulter
les déclarations fiscales de ses voisins
en revanche il a interdiction donc
communiquer le contenu même
partiellement ou de le publier les
déclarations des tas de fortune auprès
de la hatv des parlementaires ministres
et des personnel politique sont
également consultables dans les
préfectures par tout citoyen à ma
connaissance ces informations sont
soumises au même régime de
confidentialité que les déclarations
fiscales
est-il donc normal de les retrouver
diffuser régulièrement dans la presse
sans manifestement aucune sanction et
qu'il n'emmène par exemple que des
députés fassent publiquement mention
quelquefois même en séance du contenu
des déclarations à la hatpv de leur
collègue quelle sanctions peuvent-elles
prises et pas quelle autorité contre ces
débordements inacceptables je vous
remercie
merci Madame Edwige Diaz
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le Président votre
institution qui est la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
exerce une mission primordiale de
contrôle de la probité de l'action
publique et de ses représentants à
l'occasion de la parution de votre
rapport d'activité dans lequel vous
revenez sur la tenue de vos missions de
contrôle des déclarations de patrimoine
et d'intérêts vous avez notamment pu
utiliser les termes de trou dans la
raquette afin d'évoquer des manquements
dans la transparence de la vie politique
en France aussi bien au niveau local que
national concluant la synthèse de
l'activité de vos services pour l'année
2022 vous émettez un certain nombre de
recommandations parmi lesquels on
retrouve la nécessité de renforcer les
prérogatives de contrôle de la Haute
Autorité en lui accordant un pouvoir de
sanctions administrative pourriez-vous
revenir sur ce point s'il vous plaît en
nous donnant vos pistes de réflexion
vous avez commencé à les aborder tout à
l'heure vous préconisez également
concernant le contrôle des membres du
gouvernement l'instauration d'un
questionnaire de prévention des conflits
d'intérêts dans la semaine suivant la
nomination d'un ministre même question
pourriez-vous nous préciser comment
envoyer les choses et quel serait
éventuellement votre pouvoir de
coercition enfin concernant le niveau
local vous avez estimé lors d'un
entretien à la presse que les élus
locaux sont plus exposées au lobby que
les élus nationaux un an après l'entrée
en vigueur du dispositif d'encadrement
des élus locaux quel bilan pouvez-vous
en faire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Haute Autorité de la
transparence de la vie publique d'abord
vous remercier pour votre rapport pour
le bilan aussi tout le travail depuis de
nombreuses années de votre autorité la
transparence de la vie publique et qui
je crois répond à une aspiration
profonde de la société française
d'améliorer la qualité des gouvernants
et des responsables publics récemment
une actualité nous alarmes c'est la
perte de l'agrément de l'association
anticorps qui comme vous le savez est un
élément décisif une composante décisive
de cette lutte pour la probité des
responsables publics dans notre pays en
réalité j'ai regardé
l'évolution de ce dossier
l'arrêté prolongeant l'agrément
d'anticorps qui a été pris par le
Premier ministre Jean-Castet en 2021
était en réalité mal rédigé mal fagoté
il reconnaissait que les obligations
légales
qui doivent qui doivent auquel doivent
être un anticorps c'est-à-dire le fait
d'être désintéressé
le fait d'avoir un fonctionnement normal
et n'était pas mis en cause mais il y
avait une rédaction qui semblait dire le
contraire résultat des courses le
tribunal administratif n'a pu faire
autrement en 2023 que Daniels est
agrément alors
c'est une situation qui est très
dommageable est-ce que est-ce que vous
ne pensez pas qu'il y a dès le départ un
problème dans l'idée même que c'est
l'exécutif qui accorde cet agrément
c'est à dire est-ce que c'est pas
l'autorité est-ce que c'est normal que
ce soit l'autorité contrôlée en quelque
sorte qui dit qui accepte ou qui donne
l'autorisation de contrôler est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que peut-être il
faudrait pas du tout d'agrément comme ça
existe dans certains pays ou alors que
cet agrément soit délivré par la Haute
Autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique c'est une proposition qui a été
fait pardon de nombreux législateurs et
d'ailleurs nous pourrions en débattre
très rapidement dans le cadre de la loi
d'orientation de programmation pour la
justice qui va être discuter examinée
ici en début juillet
sur Raphaël j'ai une berger
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique merci pour votre propos
introductif mes questions se
concentreront sur cette notion nouvelle
de possibilités de conflits d'intérêt
entre deux intérêts publics vous avez
souligné dans votre propos introductif
qui a qu'en France qu'on avait imaginé
cela ça n'est pas sans poser un certain
nombre d'interrogations dans le
quotidien de l'exercice des mandats et
je pense notamment aux mandat locaux
puisque dans toutes les collectivités
le système délibératif est devenu
particulièrement complexe avec des
déports quasi systématique sur toutes
les délibérations qui concerne dès
qu'elle concerne des des structures
satellites des collectivités des
associations dans lesquelles l'un ou
l'autre élu pourrait avoir pourrait
avoir des intérêts or il se trouve
souvent
que dans un certain nombre de
collectivités les élus sièges dans ces
associations je pense souvent dans les
conseils d'administration au titre de
leur mandat et ont été préalablement
envoyés par la collectivité en mission
confiée siégé occupé une fonction qui
revient de droit à un une personne
désignée par la collectivité et
finalement on se retrouve dans des
systèmes où les collectivités organisent
les déports de façon plus ou moins à
droite dans des volumes conséquents à
l'occasion de commission permanente
séance publique
en créant quasi systématiquement un
risque juridique sur les délibérations
pour les éluses tu personnelles alors
qu'ils ne font que représenter la
collectivité au sein de ces conseils
d'administration comment est-ce que vous
voyez l'évolution de de ce sujet là qui
est finalement un des grands pourvoyeurs
de de ce concept de conflits d'intérêts
entre intérêts publics localement qui
qui reste
relativement abstrait madame Blandine
Broca
merci à Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président Migaud votre autorité mes
collègues l'ont dit fonctionne bien très
bien et même il me semble que ça
pourrait être un modèle de ce que
pourrait être nombre de nos autres
autorités et indépendantes d'abord
accompagné conseiller puis conseiller
encore avant de contrôler et de
sanctionner via le parquet vous l'avez
rappelé deux points que je souhaiterais
soulever ça me semble tellement bien
fonctionné que l'on est tenté de vous
confier toujours plus de tâches on
pourrait évoquer par exemple le contrôle
de la transparence et des conflits
d'intérêts des médias de tout type
d'influence ou comme cela semble être
question de certains types
d'associations celles si j'ai bien lu
votre rapport habilité à Esther en
justice mais j'ai donc senti quelquefois
dans votre rapport ici ou là une sorte
d'appel à l'aide comme quoi vous seriez
un peu débordé page 78 le traitement de
ces dossiers est devant respecter un
délai de 15 jours un tel nombre de
saisines sur une période aussi courte a
constituer une contrainte
particulièrement forte pour le collège
première série de questions quelle
prérogative seriez-vous en mesure
d'acquérir vous avez évoqué le pouvoir
de sanction administrative et avec quels
moyens second point qui concerne la
transparence à laquelle je suis nous
sommes attachés je m'interroge cependant
sur les données publiées patrimonial
notamment et sur l'utilisation qui en
effet ce qui devrait naître qu'une sorte
d'état des lieux d'entrée sortie et de
prévention des conflits d'intérêts me
semble malheureusement être
essentiellement utilisé pour stigmatiser
tel ou telle possession d'un élu ou d'un
ministre la situation de son conjoint
voire l'absence de patrimoine qui
devient suspecte ça m'est arrivé mais je
n'ai en revanche jamais vu utiliser ces
publications pour souligner la probité
des élus ce qui concerne c'est important
de le rappeler une immense majorité
d'entre nous aussi monsieur le Président
pourrait-on émettre le souhait que votre
prochain rapport nous présente un état
des lieux de ce qui est fait de ces
données publiées afin d'évaluer si
l'objectif de transparence ne concourt
pas davantage à vilipender les élus plus
qu'à démontrer leur probité je vous
remercie madame Cécile
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président de la présentation
de ce rapport c'est important
effectivement que de dire 10 ans après
ce qui est devenu la hatv c'est-à-dire
une institution ancrée dans nos
institutions démocratiques ce que
j'observe c'est que les élus se
comportent bien je pense que chaque fois
qu'il y a de mauvais de mauvais
comportements il faut au regard de cela
rappeler que la très grande majorité des
élus ne sont pas dans cette disposition
c'est important pour renouer avec la
confiance dont vous nous avez fait état
alors moi j'ai plusieurs questions la
première sur les référents déontologues
qui ont été mis en place au 1er juin
2023 à destination des élus locaux et je
pense que c'est une une bonne amendement
pris par le gouvernement particulier
Sébastien Lecornu dans le cadre de la
loi citoyenneté
on a un problème local les centres de
gestion viennent me voir en me disant
nous pouvons être l'outil utile pour
organiser au niveau des collectivités
locales et en particulier les petites
communes être l'outil mettant en
correspondance le référent déontologue
qui peut exister sur le territoire et la
commune désireuse de frire et dans
l'obligation d'offrir depuis juin ce
service à ses élus pour le moment nous
avons
une difficulté avec le ministère de
l'intérieur j'ai saisi d'ailleurs Gérald
Darmanin de ce sujet et je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on clarifie ce point parce
que les élus locaux ne veulent pas que
ce soit une charge supplémentaire et la
proposition d'un
travail en lien avec le Centre de
Gestion pas obligatoire mais cette
possibilité doit leur être préservée me
semble-t-il ça c'est ma première
question et si vous pouviez agir sur ce
point si vous rejoignez ma préoccupation
je vous en remercie ma deuxième question
partager plus beaucoup de temps c'est
évidemment sur anticorps nous avons fait
une mission
qui concluait pour les associations de
capacité à agir de délivrer l'amendement
par la hatvp quels moyens du coup
devriez vous
devriez vous bénéficier madame
Marie-Agnès pour le groupe merci
monsieur le Président mais quand on
arrive dans les dernières quasiment
toutes les questions que j'avais prévues
de poser l'entité vous remercier
monsieur le Président et peut-être
apporter simplement un petit témoignage
notamment quand vous indiquez que
l'accompagnement a été beaucoup plus
important
en 2022 qu'il l'avait été auparavant et
c'est une réalité
avoir un petit
appel particulier sur notamment les
difficultés parfois on les les élus
locaux notamment quand il siège dans des
conseils régionaux très importants pour
eux-mêmes savoir quasiment dans quel
organisme il siège c'est à dire que en
début de mandat quand vous venez d'être
élu vous êtes dans un tel nombre de
lycées de
d'organismes d'associations etc que en
toute bonne foi
et bien la collectivité vous transmet
une liste et heureusement vos services
sont encore mieux informés parce qu'ils
arrivent à découvrir des organismes dans
lesquels les associations
ignorent qu'il siège toujours alors que
c'est une réalité bref ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que je pense qu'on devrait
aussi peut-être étudier puisque les
nominations des élus dans des structures
représentant les collectivités font
l'objet de délibération sur le fait que
ces mêmes collectivités soient en
capacité l de transmettre parce que vous
avez encore une fois certaines
collectivités importantes dans
lesquelles les élus sièges qui ont un
nombre d'agents qui pourraient permettre
de préremplir peut-être ces déclarations
bref comment est-ce qu'on peut continuer
à essayer d'accompagner les élus dans ce
travail de simplification parce que si
certains ont l'habitude notamment en
début de mandat il est vrai qu'en fin de
mandat et vous expliquer que il y avait
une différence entre les déclarations le
nombre de déclarations en début de
mandats en fin de mandat ce serait
peut-être une aide précieuse monsieur
jérémyordanov
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la httvp merci de votre
présentation votre travail moi j'avais
également une question sur sur les
agréments des associations
si j'ai bien compris il y en a deux des
agrément en réalité un que qui est donné
par la hdvp et un par la garde des
sceaux ou la première ministre il se
déporte et ce qui ne conviendrait pas de
fusionner les deux au profit de la hstvp
ou voilà si vous avez d'autres
suggestions sur ce
mécanisme j'avais une autre question sur
ce qu'on appelle le pantouflage et le
rétropontouflage les allers-retours en
fait entre le public et le privé c'est
vrai que il y a déjà beaucoup de
fonctions et notamment les élus ou c'est
très contrôlé il y a une saisie
obligatoire de la chatvp mais en réalité
pour une grande majorité des agents
publics la procédure de droit commun
c'est une saisine interne et dans
l'autorité hiérarchique il y a pas
d'avis htvp sauf ces in express
or cette saisine elle n'a eu lieu qu'une
seule fois en 2022 selon votre rapport
et vous le dites vous-même ce constat
laisse planer un doute quant à la
réalisation effective du contrôle par
les administrations moi j'ai en tête le
un exemple qui s'est passé récemment le
cas d'une administratrice principale
affaires maritimes détachées au prix
auprès du lobby urbain de la pêche
industrielle sans avis subsidiaire de
htvp et viser par la suite par une
enquête pour prise illégale d'intérêt
une enquête je signale au passage
déclenché par
un signalement d'anticorps d'où ma
question ne faudrait pas t-il pas
élargir la liste des fonctions visées
par la saisine obligatoire de la HTV et
ce que vous en auriez les moyens est-ce
que sinon les faudrait-il pas les les
augmenter et après j'étais très
intéressé par le ce que vous disiez sur
le manque de saisine du parquet suite à
au fait que les injonctions n'étaient
pas respectées donc je suis assez
sensible à ce que vous proposez pour
étendre le pouvoir de sanctions
administratives de l'htvp merci
Marie-France Loreau
oui merci président monsieur le
Président de la hatvp chers collègues
dans les propositions formulées par la
Haute Autorité à la transparence de la
vie publique vous envisagez
l'amélioration du contrôle des mobilités
entre les secteurs publics et privés
vous aspirez notamment à créer un
contrôle des mobilités vers le secteur
privé pour certaines catégories d'agents
issues des pics de l'État ou
d'établissement public spéciaux cette
problématique me semble légitime
notamment parce que les intérêts de
certaines institutions privées peuvent
entrer en contradiction directe avec
ceux de la nation or pour prévenir tout
atteinte à ses intérêts fondamentaux il
apparaît essentiel que ce contrôle du
passage du public au privé s'exerce
également dans les hautes sphères de
l'État il me semble par exemple
particulièrement délicat que d'anciens
ministres puissent prétendre à des
postes dans la sphère privée dépendant
du même domaine d'exercice que leur
portefeuille passée ma question est donc
la suivante même si dans votre Pompeo et
votre exposé luminaire j'ai eu une
partie de la réponse à quel poste
entendez-vous étant de ce contrôle des
profils passants du public au privé
peut-on s'attendre à ce que ce contrôle
agisse de manière rétroactive de manière
à ce qu'une personnalité ayant
précédemment occupée un rôle important
auprès de l'État soit prémunié de toute
tentation d'usées de son réseau et de
ses compétences qu'il a qui au service
de l'État pour des intérêts privés je
vous remercie
monsieur George
oui ça marche merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de la
haptpv
en préliminaire je voudrais dire que je
suis quand même étonné qu'il y ait
encore parmi nous des députés qui se
plaignent de la transparence puisque
c'est un petit peu la teneur de ce que
je viens d'entendre au motif que ce
serait une investigation
exagérée de la part des citoyens de
connaître le patrimoine de leur
représentants alors moi ma question va
porter sur le site qui permet à tout
citoyen de prendre connaissance d'une
partie des intérêts des de leurs élus
aujourd'hui c'est un site qui fonctionne
relativement bien qui est relativement
simple et ergonomique mais il est quand
même étonnant qu'il y ait une
dissociation entre le patrimoine foncier
immobilier et le patrimoine immobilier
alors les valeurs mobilières sont
connues on a pu voir par exemple que
pendant la discussion sur la loi
retraite on a pu établir certains
certaines possessions qui pouvaient
laisser entendre qu'il y a un conflit
d'intérêt entre ce que vote les élus
aussi monsieur le Président on s'en
souvient très bien et et les textes sur
lesquels portaient la discussion en
hémicycle mais moi je reviens sur la
question du patrimoine foncier
immobilier pourquoi n'a-t-il pas le même
traitement que le patrimoine immobilier
dans la mesure où par exemple des
décisions portant sur la construction de
tel ou tel autoroute par exemple
mettrait en conflit d'intérêt des élus
qui ont en raison d'un potentiel d'une
potentiel propriété foncière traversée
par l'adite autoroute par exemple on
comprend bien que il serait quand même
pertinent de pouvoir être éclairé sur ce
point sans avoir besoin de passer par
une démarche beaucoup plus sophistiquée
qui est celle de la demande en
préfecture et je pense que ça
contribuerait également à
affiner la confiance des citoyens dans
leurs élus
la parole à Monsieur oligo je pense pas
qu'on gagne collectivement à s'accuser
mutuellement de conflit d'intérêt
lorsque l'achat TVP elle-même a démontré
que nous sommes des élus qui avons une
certaine probité et qui a pu rendre
public tous ces éléments à l'égard de
nos collègues Monsieur Thomas rudigault
et ensuite vous répondrez monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président mégot je
souhaiterais aller sur un autre spectre
de questions qui concerne le statut de
l'élu local il y a beaucoup de questions
car nous avons aujourd'hui de plus en
plus de difficultés à tirer des
personnes vers les fonctions des locaux
ou des lieux nationaux pour différentes
raisons qui peuvent être allés des
violences qui subissent aux incertitudes
professionnelles que cela peut entraîner
et justement l'une d'entre elles
concerne notamment la reconversion
professionnelle des élus en fin de
mandat je pense particulièrement aux
élus locaux ça peut concerner évidemment
les députés les parlementaires notamment
ceux qui sont des fois dans des des
collectivités de de taille moyenne et
qui quitte leur emploi pour
occuper presque 100% ou même à 75% la
fonction pour laquelle ils ont été élus
or la loi aujourd'hui offre peu de
protection il existe un droit à
l'arrêteraction qui permet un élu de
suspendre son contrat et de retrouver
son emploi à l'issue de son mandat mais
celui-ci s'éteint après un mandat ainsi
certains engagement plusieurs années se
retrouvent en difficulté parfois à
l'issue de ce de ce mandat j'ai
plusieurs questions à vous poser
monsieur le Président pourriez-vous nous
indiquer ce que la Haute Autorité
pourrait préconiser comme évolution du
statut de l'élu afin de concilier
d'essayer de conseiller le nécessaire
besoin de contrôle des activités
exercées pour prévenir les conflits
d'intérêts et le besoin pour un élu de
retrouver une activité en fin de mandat
quel serait selon vous les risques en
matière de conflit d'intérêt si la
pratique d'une suspension du contrat de
travail avec une garantie de retrouver
son emploi venait à s'élargir par
exemple est-ce que la hatvp
s'interrogerait sur les liens qui
persistent entre l'élu et l'entreprise
est-ce que ce sont des cas déjà signalés
est-ce que vous avez déjà pu travailler
sur ces questions et quels sont vos
moyens de contrôle pour vous assurer que
les réserves et les avis négatifs que
vous émettez sont respectés là je vais
sur une autre partie je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président
merci pour
vos questions qui sont nombreuses
certaines se recoupent je vais essayer
de de répondre à chacune de vos de vos
questions tout d'abord sur la
transparence
et le caractère public ou non des
déclarations
seuls les déclarations de patrimoine des
membres du gouvernement et des membres
du collège de la Haute Autorité sont
rendus publics sur le site de la Haute
Autorité
c'est de l'ordre de selon le nombre de
membres du gouvernement ça peut varier
bon c'est entre 40 et 45 le plus souvent
plus les 13 membres du collège de la
Haute Autorité voilà c'est à peu près
55 personnes qui voient leur déclaration
de patrimoine
rendu public dans leur intégralité pour
les parlementaires que ce soit les
députés les sénateurs et les députés
européens les déclarations de patrimoine
sont consultables en préfecture et
effectivement avec des conditions
strictes on doit prendre rendez-vous
on ne doit pas avoir de de crayon de
stylos on peut pas prendre de
photographies on doit pas avoir son
téléphone portable bon et on n'a pas le
droit d'en faire état c'est un peu comme
pour
il y a très peu de consultations
il y a très très peu de consultation
en préfecture on a oui c'est une
cinquantaine par an bon compte tenu du
du public concerné c'est vraiment très
peu de choses d'autant que une
consultation peut une personne peut
vouloir consulter plusieurs
déclarations donc c'est il y a très très
peu de consultations
ça ce sont donc pour
les élus pour les élus locaux les
déclarations de patrimoine ne sont pas
rendus publics
les déclarations d'intérêt les
déclarations d'intérêts des ministres
des parlementaires et des élus locaux
sont publiés et sont rendus public
sur le site de la Haute autorité dont
sont accessibles à la fois aux citoyens
et aux médias
les déclarations de patrimoine des
fonctionnaires et les déclarations
d'intérêts des fonctionnaires ne sont
pas rendus publics elles sont contrôlées
mes parents du public ça c'est ce qu'a
voulu le législateur et le Conseil
constitutionnel qui a fait une
distinction au niveau de la transparence
entre ceux qui sont élus et ceux qui ne
sont pas avec des obligations de
transparence plus fortes pour celles et
ceux qui effectivement sont élus alors
dans la déclaration d'intérêt ce qui je
pense explique votre question vous avez
un certain nombre d'éléments concernant
vos rémunérations sur les cinq dernières
années où les intérêts que vous pouvez
avoir à travers des actions que vous
possédez mais ça je dirais c'est rendu
public dans votre déclaration d'intérêt
c'est pas du tout un non respect de la
confidentialité c'est rendu public bon
une fois de plus c'est le législateur
qui l'a qui l'a voulu nous n'avons
aucune marge de manœuvre nous sur le
caractère public ou pas de vos
déclarations et les rubriques d'ailleurs
ont été définis par la loi bon alors
peut-être qu'il conviendrait de
regarder ce qui pourrait être modifié
sans remettre en cause d'ailleurs
l'objectif de transparence mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a parfois des rubriques qui
pourraient être regroupées bon
c'est ce qui n'ont pas besoin de de
faire l'objet d'une d'une publication
intégrale bon qui pourrait confiner du
voyeurisme mais mais mais voilà mais
tout ça ça peut effectivement se
regarder mais ça relève en tout cas de
la loi et il nous faudrait à nouveau
véhicule législatif pour également pour
éventuellement
adapté le dispositif sans une fois de
plus remettre en cause l'objectif de
transparence qui était
voulu donc voilà donc vous avez ces je
pense que les
ce que vous avez pu constater au niveau
des informations qui sont rendus public
et qui paraissent vous remettre en cause
la confidentialité d'un certain nombre
de de d'éléments d'information
concernant plus directement le
patrimoine c'est en fait à travers la
déclaration d'intérêt que ces
informations sont sont données mais il y
a et tout le monde respecte je crois le
le la confidentialité et le secret nous
avons en tout cas ce qui nous concerne
non mais à chaque fois les exemples qui
m'ont été donnés sur éventuellement des
des choses qui étaient rendues publiques
en fait vous les retrouvez dans la
déclaration d'intérêts et la déclaration
d'intérêt une fois de plus elle est
rendue publique le législateur a prévu
qu'elle soit rendue publique les actions
que vous détenez dans un PEA ou pas bon
c'est dans la déclaration d'intérêt
donc voilà les rémunérations sur les
cinq années précédent que vous avez pu
percevoir à titre professionnel se
retrouvent dans la déclaration
d'intérêts et cette déclaration
d'intérêt est rendue et rendue publique
sur
d'autres questions qui qui ont pu être
déposer
on n'est pas encore en mesure de faire
un bilan sur l'extension du registre des
représentants d'intérêts au niveau local
dans le mois qui suit on devrait pouvoir
le faire on est actuellement en train de
collecter un peu tout cela pour pour
vous en faire un
bilan j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
préciser tout à l'heure qu'il y a eu
300 inscriptions supplémentaires qui
semblent être liées justement à cette
extension du répertoire aux
décideurs locaux bon mais cela dit
nous invitons vraiment le législateur à
prendre des des mesures de précision et
de et de correction du dispositif de
régulation du lobbying bon si si vous
voulez que le dispositif que vous avez
mis en place soit soit efficace et
répondre à vos objectifs de transparence
il faut quand même mettre fin à toutes
ces possibilités de contourner le
dispositif qui était mis en place ça
fait plusieurs années qu'on attire votre
attention là-dessus bon je reconnais
qu'il y a une certaine réticence de la
part d'une partie de notre haute
administration sur l'ensemble de ces de
ces sujets il faut pouvoir bien sûr en
parler à avec elle et puis il faut se
mettre à la page quoi il faut il faut
penser que qu'on est au 21e siècle et
que ces sujets de transparence bon
beaucoup d'autres pays les mettent en
place sans que ça remette en cause
d'ailleurs en quoi que ce soit
l'efficacité que peut avoir ou telle
entreprise dans son secteur on dit
parfois que c'est des démarches
excessives bon qui peuvent remettre en
cause la capacité à agir aussi bien des
décideurs publics que des décideurs
privés donc quand vous regardez ce qui
se passe au Canada ou ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis où vous avez un système
de régulation du lobbying qui est encore
plus opérationnelle que le nôtre ça a
pas l'air de les gêner au niveau de
l'efficacité économique tant des
décideurs publics que des décideurs
privés donc je pense qu'il y a un
certain nombre de
d'ajustements qui peuvent être faits
dans dans le dans le dispositif sur le
conflit d'intérêts publics
c'est un vrai sujet je le reconnais
d'ailleurs j'avais fait partie
comme premier président de la Cour des
comptes avec le premier président de la
cour d'appel de Paris là Jean-Claude
magendy et Jean-Marc Sauvé de la
commission dite sauvée sur les conflits
d'intérêts où nous avions formulé un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
des bouché d'ailleurs sur la la loi de
2013 nous n'avions pas proposé ce
conflit d'intérêt publics bon vu la
difficulté
à le concrétiser et à le mettre à le
mettre en place donc voilà mais le
législateur en a décidé autrement bon et
dodo d'où les difficultés
d'interprétation que l'on peut avoir
notamment au niveau local
ou beaucoup de de collectivités
effectivement désigne des élus pour
représenter leurs collectivité dans un
certain nombre d'entités d'entités
publiques voilà
alors la loi 3DS a clarifié un certain
nombre de choses et
utilement nous avions formulé d'ailleurs
des propositions dans dans ce cadre et
nous avons publié d'ailleurs un tableau
qui précise un peu les choses en
fonction de ce cas souhaité préciser le
le législateur il y a encore
vraisemblablement peut-être
des petites choses qui mériteraient
d'être complétées mais au moins ça a
clarifié les choses parce que de temps
en temps pouvait être confronté
d'ailleurs à des référents déontologues
qui se montraient excessif dans les
propositions de déport qu'il proposait
aux élus en interdisant par exemple de
participer à tout débat à des élus qui
représentaient leur collectivité dans
une entité et qui du coup ne pouvait pas
participer au débat concernant le
rapport d'activité de ces entités bon
tout de suite nous avons considéré que
de telles demandes étaient totalement
injustifiées on a aussi un principe
général du droit dans notre pays qui est
un bon principe qui est qu'on doit
rendre des comptes bon et à partir du
moment où on est désigné par sa
collectivité pour représenter cette
collectivité dans un établissement
public ou autre et bien on doit pouvoir
rendre des comptes et donc répondre aux
questions de ces pairs au niveau de
l'Assemblée donc nous avons pu préciser
cela et la loi 3DS d'ailleurs a prévu
que lorsque la loi prévoit cette
représentation par la collectivité le
nombre de déports
est limité bon donc voilà il y a si vous
le souhaitez on pourra vous vous
adresser là monsieur le Président un
tableau que nous avons fait qui montre
que le législateur a souhaité écarter
tout risque
dans un certain nombre de situations je
pense par exemple au niveau du CCAS ou à
la caisse du sous des écoles bon là il y
a aucun intérêt aucun conflit d'intérêts
publics il y a une autre catégorie où le
risque est circonscrit à certains actes
c'est à chaque fois que le législateur a
prévu cette représentation
et nous considérons
nous interprétons en ce qui nous
concerne au niveau du collège de la
hatvp largement se cassé législateur en
disant
que le législateur les prévu
expressément ou les sous-entendus bon
donc ça ça ouvre une possibilité et là
les il n'y a pas de déport sauf quand
l'élu lui-même est concerné directement
ou qu'il s'agit de de
marcher ou de concession donc un certain
nombre de de
d'actes qui qui nécessitent le déport en
revanche pour tout le reste le risque
est large et notamment lorsqu'un élu est
membre d'une association a des
responsabilités dans une association il
faut effectivement qu'il puisse se
déporter lorsqu'une subvention est
attribuée à cette association ou
lorsqu'une décision concerne cette
association
donc voilà donc là il faut être très
très vigilant il y avait
il y a quelques années là la gestion de
fait bon qui était opposé aux élus c'est
à dire des élus qui avait des
responsabilités dans une association qui
était telle qu'on pouvait considérer que
c'était une gestion de fait là il peut y
avoir un conflit d'intérêt et vous avez
une jurisprudence de la chambre
criminelle de la Cour de cassation qui
est stricte en la matière et si vous
avez pris part à une délibération
concernant une entité avec laquelle vous
pouvez avoir un intérêt
vous pouvez tout à fait être sanctionné
et vous devez vous déporter et le déport
consiste à sortir de la salle si cette
condition n'est pas remplie bon le juge
pénal peut vous sanctionner ça c'est la
loi et les décisions
potentiel bon alors nous avions formulé
un certain nombre de propositions ce qui
explique les dispositions que vous avez
prises dans la Doua 3DS nous avions
formulé aussi quelques propositions sur
l'écriture de l'article 432 12 du code
pénal qui définit le conflit d'intérêt
bon nous avions proposé substituer
l'intérêt quelconque avec un intérêt de
nature à compromettre la dépendance
l'impartialité l'objectivité de de
l'administration bon il y a encore
vraisemment un petit travail qu'il
faudrait pouvoir prolonger nous y sommes
tout à fait prêts donc avec vous avec
les magistrats de l'or judiciaire pour
voir si sur les deux articles qui
concernent notamment ces conflits
d'intérêts l'article 432 12 et puis
l'article 43213
notamment s'agissant des projets de
reconversion professionnelle il y a
peut-être un petit travail d'écriture
pour éviter que que des personnes
puissent être mises en cause alors même
que bon
il y avait pas d'intérêt en tant que que
tel en cause donc voilà donc c'est je
pense qu'il y a eu des progrès de fait
mais je mesure que il y a peut-être
encore quelques marches de progrès que
ça peut entraîner quelques difficultés
d'organisation au niveau de collectivité
quand il s'agit notamment de de
large délibération qui font état de
beaucoup de subventions bon c'est vrai
que il faut il faut être rigoureux et
voir sur chaque subvention comment
doivent s'organiser les déports et ça
une fois de plus c'est la loi et c'est
les conséquences de de définition
du législateur et puis de
l'interprétation quand on fait le juge
le juge pénal alors c'est pour ça que
nous efforçons de beaucoup accompagner
les les élus j'écris beaucoup aux élus
pour pour justement faire en sorte de
les prévenir par rapport à ce type de de
situation dans l'ensemble d'ailleurs il
y a une
attention
bon une grande attention lorsque nous
écrivons aux élus et que nous leur
préconisons un certain nombre de mesures
pour prévenir toute situation de conflit
d'intérêt sachant que là j'insiste là
dessus la déclaration d'intérêt que vous
devez remplir vous concerne
personnellement
concerne votre conjoint
elle ne doit pas vous interdire de
réfléchir à tout autre situation de
conflits d'intérêt que vous pourriez
rencontrer et il y a intérêt à le faire
même si la loi ne prévoit pas une
rubrique pour d'autres personnes parce
que le juge pénal peut considérer
qu'il y a privilégal d'intérêt à partir
du moment où les parents des enfants un
ami peuvent être concernés bon donc
si vous avez le droit d'avoir des amis
mais pas obligatoirement ensuite bon
prendre des décisions
pouvant être de nature à compromettre
justement l'indépendance l'objectivité
l'impartialité de l'administration c'est
cette fameuse jurisprudence de la
chambre criminelle de la Cour de
cassation qui
a considéré qu'un partenaire de golf
pour un maire pouvait entraîner de sa
part une situation de conflit d'intérêt
et même de prise illégale d'intérêt
voilà donc voilà mais c'est une
jurisprudence pour qu'il puisse y avoir
j'en suis conscient nous le disons aussi
une parce que selon le département dans
lequel vous êtes vous pouvez avoir
effectivement une politique pénale un
peu différente donc qui puisse y avoir
au niveau de la Chancellerie des
précisions quant à la politique pénale à
suivre sur un certain nombre de
situations je pense que ça pourrait être
effectivement
utile bon puisqu'on voit des situations
un peu un peu diverses selon les
départements mais voilà mais d'où la
l'accompagnement la prévention qui sont
indispensables moi j'insiste beaucoup
nous avons une équipe dédiée à la Haute
autorité qui est sous la responsabilité
de peut-être mars
qui se trouve à côté de la Secrétaire
Général de la Haute Autorité nous avons
une dizaine de personnes qui ne font que
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
pouvez poser nous sommes énormément
saisis de de
David de demande d'avis de
conseils et nous y répondons bien sûr
très très volontiers parce que nous nous
considérons que que justement l'aspect
prévention ils vont toujours mieux
prévenir que guérir bon donc il vaut
mieux faire en sorte que la personne ne
se mette pas dans une situation qui
ensuite doit entraîner une ou est
susceptible d'entraîner une sanction
voilà donc nous assistons beaucoup sur
ce sur ce sur ce volet
sur le statut de l'élu local
on se reprend un petit peu ce que ce que
j'ai dit alors effectivement les projets
de reconversion professionnelle des élus
des collectivités de plus de 20000
habitants nous sont nous sont soumis
qui puissiez avoir un sujet de statut de
l'élu local j'en conviens tout à fait
mais je dirais que c'est en dehors des
missions qui qui sont qui sont les
nôtres je sais qu'il y a une réflexion
depuis des années sur la définition de
la meilleure statue pour pour les
locales il y a vraiment des marges de
progrès par rapport à la situation
actuelle pour mieux définir ce statut
après sur la reconversion
professionnelle
il faut lorsqu'on est élu local et qu'on
se consacre totalement
assez mission de service public est
attentif justement à ne pas se trouver
en situation de conflit d'intérêt et
puis parfois quand on a été dans une
profession donnée on peut se déporter
c'est on peut se déporter sur tel ou
telle situation pour je dirais faciliter
le retour à la vie professionnelle
quand justement on souhaite que c'est
fonctions publiques
se termine donc voilà c'est l'intérêt
aussi dans les avis de prédomination que
que l'on peut exprimer on peut parfois
dire à des membres qui viennent du privé
qui viennent de telle entreprise et qui
veulent exercer des fonctions qui sont
invitées à exercer des fonctions dans un
cabinet ministériel attention il faudra
que vous déportiez sur tel ou tel sujet
correspondant à l'entreprise dans le
vous avez été salarié honnêtement ça les
protège et puis ça leur permet surtout à
la fin de leur fonction d'y retourner
sans qu'on puisse le reposer une
possible prise illégale d'intérêt donc
c'est pour ça que les déports sont sont
peuvent être très utiles dans l'exercice
des fonctions alors après lorsque le
déport devient trop important ça finit
par ne plus avoir de sens et et là ça
équivoine incompatibilité mais il faut
pouvoir le regarder cela dit
ce que j'entends cette petite musique
qui consiste à dire que les
reconversions professionnelles dans le
privé sont impossibles pour celles et
ceux qui exercent des fonctions
publiques
j'avoue que je suis étonné quand
j'entends des personnes
s'exprimèrent ainsi ils ignorent que
près de 94% des avis on sent des avis de
compatibilité alors certes parfois avec
des réserves mais qui peuvent tout à
fait ce justifier compte tenu des
fonctions qui ont été exercées par la
personne et nous assumons complètement
les décisions que nous avons prises
concernant un certain nombre d'anciens
ministres et elles ont pu être parfois
galvaudé dans dans la presse ou tout à
fait mal interprété je trouve que
parfois on perd le sens des mots
bon quand on dit
on doit s'abstenir de toute démarche ça
ne doit pas être traduit par on ne peut
pas appeler bon donc une démarche ça
signifie intervenir pour je dirais d'une
certaine façon influencer la décision
compte tenu des fonctions qu'on a pu
entreprendre qu'on a pu avoir
précédemment ou bien pour fausser une
éventuelle concurrence qui peut exister
entre différentes entités ça n'interdit
pas un contact téléphonique pour
informer le ministre on a entendu
parfois des choses un peu stupides au
moment de notre décision sur Jean Castex
ou bien sur Roselyne Bachelot bon c'est
c'est le
ce que nous regardons c'est le risque
pénal et le risque déontologique le
risque pénal quand il est là
nous protégeons je pense la personne en
disant que il n'est pas possible pour
elle de rejoindre tel ou tel entreprise
j'ai vu que les décisions de la Haute
Autorité concernant monsieur Cédric au
n'était pas totalement comprises par
lui-même bon je pense que nous l'avons
protégé alors peut-être à l'insu de son
plein gré pour reprendre une expression
mais c'est peut-être utile bon nous
devons apprécier le risque pénal et le
risque déontologique bon d'autant que je
vous rappelle que la définition du
conflit d'intérêt qui a été retenu par
le législateur l'apparence compte aussi
et que nous devons prendre en compte
cette situation en tout cas c'est ce
qu'à souhaiter le législateur parfois
c'est compliqué sur le risque pénal on
est dans le droit dur ça soulève pas
trop de difficultés quand il s'agit du
risque déontologique on est dans un
droit plus souple et et c'est
effectivement
plus difficile à interpréter mais je
rappelle que toutes nos décisions sont
susceptibles de de pourvoir devant le
Conseil d'État jusqu'à maintenant le
Conseil d'État nous a toujours suivi
dans dans les avis que nous avons
exprimé peut-être la première question
concernant l'agrément
il m'appartient pas tant que président
de la hautautorité de de dire c'est tel
ou tel procédure qui doit être tenue
cela relève de du législateur de de la
loi ce que je sais c'est que nous avons
deux procédures de l'agrément
effectivement puisque nous délivrons
aussi un agrément à anticorps mais les
missions ne sont pas les mêmes bon donc
le degré d'exigence pour l'agrément
vis-à-vis de la Haute autorité n'est pas
le même que
l'agrément délivré par la Chancellerie
puisque se constituait partie civile
dans un procès dans une procédure plus
exactement c'est beaucoup plus lourd
bien évidemment que la possibilité
d'adresser des signalements à la Haute
autorité sur tel ou telle situation bon
donc voilà donc c'est la procédure
d'agrément nous aussi si bien sûr le
législateur décide de nous confier cette
mission nous la remplirons je pense que
sur ces questions moi j'avais suggéré
d'ailleurs au parlementaire qui
travaillait sur ces sujets que
préalablement à la délivrance d'un arc
gréement il puisse y avoir un contrôle
de la Cour des comptes sur
notamment toutes ces questions
budgétaires et financières bon et de
transparence ce pouvait être utile à
partir du moment d'ailleurs où la
compétence de la Cour des Comptes est
tout à fait possible puisque c'est ces
associations bénéficient d'une certaine
façon de de des mesures concernant la
générosité publique il y a des des
facilités fiscales qui qui existent
lorsque vous subventionnez ce type
d'associations vous contribuez au
financement de ce type d'association
donc sa légitime tout à fait le le
contrôle par la Cour des comptes et
à partir du moment où vous délivrez un
agrément
je pense que les centres de gestion sont
un outil utile vous avez vous avez
raison alors je sais pas pourquoi le
ministre de l'Intérieur a des réserves
faudra qu'on peut-être qu'on voit cela
qu'on se rapproche de vous madame
intermédiaire sur sur le centre de
gestion pour j'ai pas compris pourquoi
le ministère de l'Intérieur avait des
réserves on fera que que l'on voit cela
de temps en temps je regrette d'ailleurs
que
alors que nous sommes l'État français
chacun dans ses responsabilités dans ses
composantes mais de temps en temps que
les gens ne se parlent pas suffisamment
j'ai vu que la MA signalée que la DGCL
avait produit d'ailleurs un document sur
les possibles conflits d'intérêt et sur
sur
l'interprétation que l'on pourrait en
faire
[Musique]
sans nous en avoir parlé ce qui fait que
il y a parfois des
des divergences
dans les appréciations ce qui n'est pas
les élus donc c'est quand même du noir
stupidité ce type de comportement bon
donc voilà donc sachant qu'en plus c'est
à la Haute Autorité de définir la
doctrine en la matière c'est ce qui a
souhaité législateur donc c'est plutôt
bien de se rapprocher de nous quand on
publie un document de ce type qui peut
tromper les élus je l'ai appris en fin
de semaine dernière ce sont des des
situations qui sont quand même très
regrettables et qui contribuent
justement aux questions que peuvent se
poser les élus locaux en la matière
voilà mais on va essayer de voir parce
qu'une fois de plus les centres de
gestion ça fonctionne bien souvent ça
permet d'avoir plusieurs personnes
d'ailleurs qui du coup ça fait autant de
disponibilités supplémentaires pour
répondre aux élus autant une grande
collectivité à aucune difficulté pour
trouver un référent déontologue bon
notamment dans les villes universitaires
vous trouvez toujours un professeur de
un ancien magistrat de l'orge judiciaire
ou de l'ordre administratif ou financier
pour pouvoir
contribuer à
des comités de déontologie mais pour des
petites communes bon c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et là le centre de gestion ou
les associations des maires
bons peuvent parfaitement être utiles
dernière question je crois que c'était
sur le suivi des réserves et puis sur
les moyens de la Haute Autorité à partir
du moment où nous exprimons des réserves
oui il faut pouvoir les suivre sinon ça
n'aurait pas de sens bon donc si on
exprime des réserves et ensuite on dit
bon bah vogue la galère ça n'a
strictement aucune importance bon ce
serait un très mauvais signal donc il
faut que l'on puisse effectivement
suivre ces réserves donc nous
interrogeons régulièrement la personne
concernée nous croisons bien évidemment
les renseignements qu'il peut nous
donner avec d'autres informations que
nous pouvons obtenir nous avons un suivi
aussi de toutes les lettres plus ou
moins confidentielles qui peuvent
exister aussi sur bon les situations des
des responsables publics bon et nous
avons ce travail de de veille et bien
évidemment nous suivons ces situations
pendant les trois années qui suivent
alors vous dire que
que nos moyens sont totalement
suffisants pour assurer toutes nos
missions je vous mentirai si je disais
cela bon je
on a fait un certain nombre de
propositions pour augmenter
progressivement les moyens qui sont les
nôtres pour le moment nous avons obtenu
satisfaction bon et nous allons formuler
quelques propositions supplémentaires
pour pour l'année 2024 pour conforter je
dirais l'exercice de nos missions par
les personnels de la Haute Autorité
l'année 2022 j'ai été contraint avec la
secrétaire général à
contraindre
à faire
à mettre en place des permanences et des
astreintes pour une partie de notre
personnel compte tenu justement de
l'augmentation des saisines que nous
avions sur les projets de de mobilité
professionnelle quand vous avez une
augmentation de 93% et il y a beaucoup
de mouvements
bon j'ai un peu d'expérience sur ces
sujets là qu'on compte tenu de des
fonctions que j'ai pu exercer dans le
dans le passé mais
je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de mobilité
dans les cabinets ministériels un petit
peu plus qu'avant bon donc donc voilà on
reste moins longtemps semble-t-il dans
les dans les fonctions donc
dès que vous avez
des allées et des retours la Haute
Autorité est saisie donc effectivement
ça s'arrête assez peu et c'est un
mouvement un peu continu alors on a des
pics hauts mais quand même le la
tendance et est très élevé dans le
nombre de saisines que nous que nous
avons donc voilà donc c'est si les
moyens de la Haute Autorité peuvent être
augmenté j'en serai le premier heureux
voilà
oui il y a des orgelés je l'ai dit on
propose par exemple il y a quelques
trous dans la raquette effectivement bon
notamment au niveau de contrôle des des
mobilités j'avais l'occasion de répondre
à une de vos questions concernant
notamment les
militaires les magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire qui
à partir du moment où il démissionne etc
et vont rejoindre tel ou tel cabinet ou
autres sont se retrouvent sans
possibilité de contrôle et puis vous
avez des responsables d'établissement
comme solideo comme lugap qui qui mérite
d'être dans le champ bien évidemment de
la Haute Autorité donc on a formulé un
certain nombre de propositions pour
élargir le pas de manière considérable
mais il se trouve il est curieux que par
exemple le président d'un épiclocal soit
obligé de demander un avis pour sa
reconversion professionnelle
à la Haute Autorité alors même que les
patrons de solideo et du GAP n'y sont
pas contraints donc c'est quand même une
anomalie mais qui peut être facilement
rectifié par une disposition législative
bien écoutez je vous remercie cette
édition
je vous souhaite une bonne journée merci
beaucoup